What do you know about a heist at a black
market storage facility in Kazakhstan happened
a couple days ago doesn't ring a bell
you know I may not know when a
squirrel is pretending to be a human
but I sure as hell know when a human is lying
you know damn well what was in that storage fault
tells me all I need to know about this new
rather old Nick Fury I think thanos's snap
changed you taught you that no matter how hard
you fight for what's right there's always someone
stronger to undermine you you seem to forget
this old Nick Fury has 30 years of hands-on
experience with the Skrulls I know the nature
of this threat way better than you ever will
your idea of an offer of some sort of
collaboration between us we used to work pretty
well together back in the day you would have
seen my rather mediocre bagnan coming a mile away
the fact that you didn't see them
coming means you haven't a hope in
Hell of seeing graphic and his Rebels coming
which makes you as a partner rather pointless
Heroes it's an old-fashioned notion no matter
who wins or loses trouble still comes round
Nick Fury is such a central character to this
world like his access to all of these different
superheroes in the way that he seemingly
all-knowing I got my eye on you we always
knew that secret Invasion would first and
foremost focus on Nick Fury and we really
wanted to learn more about him than we had ever
learned before this is my War alone one of the
things we talk about is Nick Fury is not a
super his superpower is his persuasiveness
and fearlessness I know the nature of
this threat way better than you ever will
afternoon blip Nick Fury really questions who
he should trust he's been on saber and they
bring him down for years you've been avoiding
Earth yeah well this is different he's a Nick
Fury that we've never seen before and so that
immediately demands for a more grounded series
there's a real Espionage element to what's going
on Fury careful now hopefully it'll feel like a
different experience something grittier that
invasion is here and we can't even tell who
the Invaders are we get to really dig into Fury
and the stakes that he's having to encounter
between them and what they really want
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be my new Secret
Invasion trailer video that Marvel just
released talking a lot about Thanos the snap
The Avengers obviously episode 1 is releasing
tomorrow as I'm posting this video I will be doing
weekly episode videos so be sure to subscribe to
get those the big thing with secret invasion is
they're using it to set up what's happening in
Marvel Phase 5 and Marvel phase six heading into
Avengers 5 is part of the more earth-based plot so
there's like this large Cosmic Kang based with
the Kang Multiverse worth they're spinning up
that'll be more like Loki season 2 in the other
space based stuff most of what they're setting
up in secret invasion is like the dark rain the
villains taking over this whole Thunderbolt Ross
this Val are they're setting up on the other side
of what's happening with Nick Fury either sort of
view Val is like the antithesis of Nick Fury
which is funny because in real life Samuel L
Jackson said that Julie Louis-Dreyfus just said
that they're actually going to fight like their
characters Nick Fury and Val are going to fight
in upcoming Marvel movies I think what she was
referring to is Thunderbolt Ross becoming US
president in val getting more power like she's
already director of the CIA so it's sort of like
the antithesis in a fury to begin with just in
general but the idea that she and Thunderbolt Ross
or Thunderbolt Ross being the president will allow
her to do whatever she did before like all the
Shady stuff that they would normally classify
as Black Ops and do Under the board they can now
do in the light of day I'll talk about that in a
second because there's so much other stuff going
on in this footage there's a lot of Nick Fury and
Olivia Coleman Sonia fallsworth character talking
about Thanos in the snap and what happened after
that like what happened really after Avengers end
game and the whole idea here is that everyone in
the intelligence Community Nick Fury used to work
with on a regular basis through shield now thinks
Thanos basically broke him as a human like you're
a lump of Flesh you're useless to us now what
happened to the old Nick Fury and what they've
said is that he's basically been on the saber
space station since right after Iron Man's funeral
like red for Avengers end game he was real at the
funeral but then he left in Talos replaced him
as sort of like the villain with his wife as the
fake Maria Hill well the real Maria Hill has been
running around doing more stuff kind of like what
they did during the Agents of Shield TV show still
doing Shield type of work like the stuff that she
used to do with Nick Fury before the snap and
Thanos but now just doing it very quietly so if
it wasn't clear Maria Hill has been basically been
doing what she did before the snap after the snap
you just haven't seen as much of that look they
had the funny moment with Taylor's wife pretending
to be her but while that was happening the real
Maria Hill was still running around the world
trying to deal with stuff like you see during this
series it actually complained to Nick Fury in that
last clip that I posted like the episode one clip
where she says that Nick Fury wasn't answering her
phone calls like all these problems were happening
I've been calling you about it but you haven't
been picking up I just did a video about the
opening scene from episode one I'll link it at
the end of this video and during that Everett Ross
learns about the secret Invasion and he says he'll
contact Nick Fury but the Maria Hill clip makes
it sound like it was Talos that finally got Nick
Fury to actually come down from the saber space
station to planet Earth to deal with this like
okay finally you actually need to pay attention
to what's going on this is a big problem an evil
faction led by graphic inside our good Skrulls is
is trying to take over the planet take over all
these world leaders they did confirm that Dermot
mulrooney is playing the current U.S president
when the series picks up I don't know when he
took office or when the next U.S election is but
they say that it's 2025 like spring 2025 when the
series takes place that's meant to be relatively
present day in the MCU like Spider-Man no way home
took place before this series pretty much the most
recent Marvel movies with a few exceptions take
place around this period during the clip The Heist
Nick Fury is tracking the Skrulls stealing tech
for their special device they're building in this
abandoned power plant he mentions it happened in
Kazakhstan that could be where the abandoned power
plant is where they're building this is a former
Soviet Union territory and it seems like a lot of
the series takes place around the former Soviet
Union territories for example this big attack
in the Square this celebration is taking place
in Russia around that same area all the scenes
with Sonia fallsworth and Nick Fury though are
taking place in London the MCU has visited London
a couple times by now like they're starting to
get a little more International with the m MCU
movies she's playing British Special Agent Sonya
fallsworth she says she's supposed to be kind of
like the British version of Val even though she
and Nick Fury worked together and were cordial
in the past there's a couple new clips with Rody
and they say that by the events of this series
he's become special advisor to Derma Rooney's
U.S president and it seems like he's kind of
replaced Thunderbolt Ross in that respect like
Thunderbolt Ross was the Secretary of State so
normally he'd be the person that'd be advising
the president on security matters things like
that Thunderbolt Ross Been recast with Harrison
Ford as you've probably seen I've done a couple
Captain America four videos there's gonna be a
whole bunch of Thunderbolt Ross during that movie
because of the Red Hulk plot and U.S president
Thunderbolt Ross plot because they're using secret
Invasion to sort of lay the track work for that
what might be going on is that the world learns
about the Skrulls and this current U.S president
Dermot rule Rudy fails to win re-election because
people are so pissed off that another Thanos level
World takeover Annihilation event almost happened
like again are you kidding me the world almost got
taken over again in what might be happening just
because we know where this is ending up is that
Thunderbolt Ross uses that fear to his Advantage
is part of his campaign like dark Reign Norman
Osborne style and rides the wave of popularity
to win the U.S presidency in the next election
like his whole campaign is based on increasing
security and safety like I will make sure that
nobody ever Takes Over America again because we're
talking about the U.S presidency but he winds up
doing that by turning America into something akin
to a police state at the expense of personal
freedoms like the whole idea in Black Panther
will Connor forever is that there was a lot of
tension between World Nations everybody wanted
wakanda's resources because they were so afraid
of another takeover from someone like Thanos we
need all your vibranium because we need these
crazy weapons because we might be taken over by
some Cosmic Force Galactus has entered the chat no
amount of vibranium is going to protect them from
Galactus in fact Galactus would want every bit
of that vibranium but what they're doing during
Marvel Phase 5 in the wake of secret Invasion
like the results of the series is that Val will
start doing a lot of the Shady stuff that she did
with say like the Thunderbolts that she's creating
under the table Black Ops stuff stuff that she
couldn't have Captain America doing in the light
of day like we can't have Captain America doing
all the Shady stuff and because they're trying
to sell America on keeping it safe they can do
it and have people cheer for them even though
they're doing really morally questionable
stuff part of this plot is supposed to set
up what's happening in the armor Awards movie
reportedly Val is going to be one of the main
villains of that along with Justin hammer and
I think part of the idea is that Thunderbolt
Ross is going to Pardon Justin Hammer like he's
still been rotting in prison this whole time but
Thunderbolt Ross pardons him as long as he works
for Val and helps her steal Iron Man technology
so she can use that for damage control like
damage control will gain that technology and
they'll do some of the armor Wars comic book plot
but Val and Thunderbolt Ross will be responsible
for a lot of that happening there's a couple new
scenes of Everett Ross it sounds like he's pretty
big during the series too but they also use him
for a little bit of Comedy like it's not going
to be all completely serious although it looks
like it's way more Winter Soldier Vibes during
the series which I think people have been asking
for like a slightly darker Marvel series but the
big reminder is that secret Invasion Episode 1
is starting tomorrow as me posting this video
My Episode will be up Wednesday new episode videos
posting every Wednesday there's six episodes total
and then obviously we'll have a bunch of other
stuff coming later this year too make sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss
that click here to watch that opening scene from
Secret Invasion episode one and click here for my
brand new Marvel Kraven the Hunter Trailer video
with Quicksilver I know people will be asking all
kinds of questions about this when it comes out
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!